[Music]
bob is in camden new jersey to start off
this hour hey bob how are you
uh doing pretty well dave how about
yourself better than i deserve how can i
help
well i wanted to get your take on the
idea of purchasing a home with a land
lease agreement as being sort of a
middle of the road solution between
renting and then traditional
home ownership
so what is the structure of the deal
so basically
i would be able to purchase a home which
would be
and a decent quality smaller home like
two bedrooms one bathroom for
about a hundred thousand dollars which i
could
immediately pay most if not the entire
price and essentially have no mortgage
however i would have
to pay approximately eight hundred
dollars a month for the on the land
lease agreement so it would effectively
be a giant
um hoa agreement
and i see that as a middle of the road
solution between continuing to rent and
paying 1500 to 2 000 a month in rent
which i don't really want to do
or at the same time buying a traditional
home in south jersey which unfortunately
the average nice home in south jersey
these days you're looking at four
hundred thousand dollars which would
take on all kinds of
debt which and i'm a big believer in the
debt is dumb mentality so
being a centrist kind of guy that tries
to find answers in the middle i was
wondering if the land lease agreement
might be a happy medium for me
uh how long is the land lease
um i don't know off hand i want to say
as far as i know it would be an
indefinite agreement but yeah there is a
campaign oh it has to have a cut off
if it's if it's approaching infinity
it'd be a 50 year but they don't
um
uh a lease has to have an end date or
it's not a valid contract in any state
so um gotcha i would have i would have
to look into that more more deeply i
appreciate you bringing up that point if
it is a short lease a short-term lease a
hundred percent no
okay if it's a long-term lease
you can do it and the downside is
it's almost impossible for a buyer to
buy this from you
with traditional financing
fha va fannie mae will not write a
mortgage on this deal
so your pool of buyers
when you get ready to sell is going to
be small
thus you're not going to get much
appreciation
okay
the long-term land lease is almost never
used in a residential setting it's
typically used in a commercial setting
and it's not unusual at all to do like a
bill to suit with a long-term land lease
and you know a 25-year lease or a
30-year lease and during that time the
investor that owns the actually owns the
property so you don't own the property
uh you because the prop the dirt is not
yours you don't you're not purchasing a
house you're renting ground
and putting a house on someone else's
ground
and that that that that's the legal
position you're putting yourself in so
um
you know you what i would do if i would
use i'm going to continue to investigate
it because it's kind of an interesting
different concept and try to continue to
poke holes in it uh having done
3 000 real estate deals in my life
including a couple of them with 50-year
leases on commercial deals
i would not do this deal
because i don't think it's got a good
upside resale on the back end even if
it's the best of situations
because it's such a weird
deal it's so unusual
that it's going to be hard to get
financing hard to get buyers off the
back end anytime you have a limited pool
of buyers off the back end you're going
to get limited appreciation
and it's going to make you wish you had
just gone ahead and done the other
regular traditional deal yeah this
sounds like it's better than rent to own
but it still has some risks involved
yeah because you don't fully own it well
it's approaching a condominium
situation i mean with a condo
you don't technically own the dirt under
your condo you may not even own the
i mean you may you maybe your condo
might be sitting on someone else's condo
it could be a my town home i don't own
the dirt
you don't on yours because the town home
is one giant structure yeah so okay you
know then that's just a similar
situation yeah and so but the the
difference is that the that is a
traditional deal it's not a lease
in that that's a it's a condominium
document
um or in new york they they will use a
different document called a co-op
document but it still works very similar
to a condominium document but that that
you can get permanent financing on yeah
not that i want you to get permanent
financing but the you want to have
something that
can get financed when you get ready to
sell it because that's going to limit
your market otherwise if cash buyers are
your only buyer coming back in
you you know you're not going to get
much appreciation it still sounds like
this is kind of a shortcut i would just
go ahead and save up a down payment do
traditional financing on you know a home
in south jersey i would get 20 or 15 on
a 400 000 house and yeah do it that way
but i also couldn't resist investigating
it further just because oh yeah you love
real estate i always like getting into
weird deals and figuring out what's
going on